it's been another hit for Obamacare
health insurer Aetna announced it will
be pulling out of 11 of the 15 states
where it has been participating in the
Affordable Care Act this follows other
major insurers such as United Health and
Humana who also exited the exchanges
here with more is Bloomberg News health
care reporters actraiser
and Zach I really have two questions one
is how can it be that Aetna is losing so
much money on this and number two what
is this to do Obamacare so the first one
first when we first had Obamacare it was
thought this would be a boon potentially
for health insurer x' because millions
of people had to have health insurance
how can they be losing hundreds of
millions of dollars you know insurers
have pointed to a few problems with
Obamacare one issue has just been a lot
more sick people signing up a lot fewer
young healthy people signing up than
anybody expected there's also questions
about you know did they charge too
little we've seen insurers for next year
raising premiums something like 23 24
percent the ones that are sticking
around so you know there's there's a few
different ways that they may have really
gotten this market wrong and now they're
paying the price but but originally with
the Affordable Care Act it was thought
that we're going to have mandatory
participation to avoid the problem of
the cherry-picking with the sick people
getting insurance the well people not
what happened to that that's right you
know you are required by law to have
health insurance in this country and you
pay a penalty if you don't but it's
turned out to just be such an expensive
product that people aren't willing to do
buy it people that don't have a lot of
health problems they'd rather pay the
fine than pay you know it might be
several thousand dollars a year for
health insurance so all those well
people are basically paying the fine
getting out of it and it's leaving the
health insurers with the sick people
that's right that appears to be at least
one of the things that's happening here
what does this mean as a practical
matter if you are right now participate
in an anti plan it's 11 out of 15 states
and I see in some of those states
there'll be one health insurer left what
does it mean if I'm buying my health
insurance right now that's right so if
you're buying health insurance from Edna
as an individual on in ACA exchange
you're gonna have to go shopping in
November you're gonna have to go and and
basically get health insurance from a
new provider it could be higher costs it
means you may not have the doctors that
you want in your network okay in a word
how bad is it for Obamacare hey this
could be a real challenge real problem